alors rokhaya diallo bonsoir dont
il assure qu'elle est présidente des
indivisibles les indivisibles ça vient
de la constitution française qui dit la
france est une république indivisible
pour vous en faites la peau l'origine la
religion ne doivent pas donner lieu à
une désignation particulière on est pas
noir en fait je suis une française je
suis pas une française d'origine x ou y
mais il suit de telle ou telle souche
immigrés je suis une française comme les
autres alors tout à fait volontiers
alors vous allez organiser en 2009 les
premiers y'a bon awards alors ça c'est
énorme les y'a bon awards c'est des
césar qui récompense les meilleures
blagues racistes
alors voilà donc il ya eu un fils
quelques routes voilà évidemment luc
ferry ivan rioufol du figaro évidemment
et zemmour était nominé mais il a rien
eu non il a été battu par eric raoult
teint est il écrit il était en bonne
position effectivement vous êtes
surpasser mais je pense que vous serez
candidat
genre n'ont jamais est récurrent et on
sait
une volonté de gagner warner eric à la
fin de votre livre mélancolie française
vous dites que l'échec de l'intégration
des immigrés met en péril l'identité
française j'explique que nous avions un
modèle d'assimilation qui est qu' il n'y
a aucune différence entre les français
qu'il n'y a pas de différences de race
etc et que simplement alors j'allais
dire en échange
l'immigré se font dans la dans la
communauté nationale et renoncent à une
partie de ce qui est lui-même pour
adopter les moeurs les us et coutumes de
la france et donc chaque génération
d'immigrés
comment dire s'approprient ces codes
culturels et à partir des années 70 80
on a eu des revendications de droit à la
différence et 2 c'est pour ça qu'on a
renoncé au mot assimilation et on à
l'intégration qui ne veut rien dire et
on a en fait un régime bâtard qui est
que les nouveaux immigrés ne s'assimile
plus veulent garder des coutumes qui ne
sont pas à prendre à la france et d'où
le choc si vous voulez entre une
population que vous appelez comme vous
voulez autochtones de souche et c'est un
bref et des nouveaux enfants d'immigrés
qui eux disent ben on a on nous demande
augmente des choses nous on a on a fait
ce qu'il fallait on est français puis
voilà et les autres qui disent ah oui
mais ils sont pas assimilés comme
l'étaient les fils d'italiens les pistes
espagnoles et c'est faux de parler comme
si vous considérez que la france avait
une identité qui était monolithique et
figée elle évolue elle évolue on mange
bien sûr que si elle évolue moi je vous
ai entendu par exemple critiqué le fait
qu'une ministre de la justice prénomme
son enfance aura il ya aujourd'hui des
français qui s'appelle mois m la peine
nous loupons ne sont pas moins français
que vous mais je ne vois pas en quoi le
fait que vous a péri et que vous
appeliez eric fait de vous un meilleur
français dans cette masse à l'appel
rokhaya midi l'assimilation quand on
veut être français on prend un prénom
français fait l'effort de rentrer dans
les moules tueur est alors ce que
j'aimerais que vous m'expliquez c'est en
quoi le fait que je porte le prénom jeu
portrait de moi une non assimilés une
par une française au moins française
mais c'est que les personnes qui portent
un mail
vous construit depuis 1500 ans sur j'ai
expliqué rome et le christianisme donc
je me posais une question si vous ne
l'avez pas répondre ses parts et reste
donc le christianisme imprègne ce pays à
fabriquer ce pays le christianisme ya
des prénoms chrétiens vous savez qu'il
ya encore trente ans le préfet
interdisait aux parents de donner des
prénoms non chrétiens qui n'étaient pas
dans le calendrier il y a deux lois
genève 1906 et si la guinée où je vous
interromps parce que je vous demande pas
un cours d'histoire je vous demande
juste une réponse à une question du
voile à ma réponse elle est faite
on veut nos six syndicats ja c'est joli
mais c'est un fait il y en a pas un en
français c'est joli ça me plaît sacha
alors voilà c'est joli tu sautes ça me
plaît oui et ça peut tomber s'est passée
la libérera mère absolue n'est pas
constitutif d'une aciérie pour
constituer une nation il faut des
disciples un mois mademoiselle c'est mon
histoire mais moi aussi mouloud ses mots
et maux 6 1 c'est l'histoire de notre
pays comme moche et c'est l'histoire de
notre pays mon cher et c'est ça qui je
ferai la france moderne aujourd'hui il
ya que du pessimisme chez toi c'est ça
que je pouvais être ton père et je serai
au désespéré de voir monfils jouer aussi
pessimiste que ça je pense que tu
mélange à la fois le plan politique
social et culturel et tu fais un espèce
de 2,2 de bouillabaisse pour pour
arriver à un propos qui te fait
rapprocher de l'extrême droite comme
dans les années 30 est avec saint juif
bon ce que je veux te dire cinq ans
nommé temps l'attention internationale
no no no no on n'est pas d'accord avec
eux donc en jce quatre essais fascisme
et racines oms et les mêmes méthodes tu
ne niera pas que d'avoir la couleur de
peau qu'elle a un ou s'appeler de telle
ou telle façon fait que tu n'as pas la
même situation qu'en france face à un
policier et une face à une amie j'ai dit
juste c'est une honte c'est pour ça que
les gens donner des prénoms dits
français ont catholique mais c'est
justement pour montrer qu'il faisait un
effort que les prénoms ne change pas la
couleur de peau ni le faciès et
montagnards va par exemple précis le
quick burger halal alors éric parle de
la halalisation de la france parce que
justement contrairement à ce que ils
prétendent à ma droite les gens ne se
mélangent plus mais se sépare parce
qu'ils ne veulent plus vivre ensemble
parce que justement c'est un danger on
avait remis à chacun et à chaque groupe
au nom de la liberté individuelle
défendu par la nuit à ma gauche en fait
c'est la liberté de la tribu et du
groupe d'imposer ses règles
si je peux me permettre je pense que les
quartiers notamment populaires sont
organisés de cette manière là parce que
il ya une ségrégation spatiale qui est
qui et qui existent pour des raisons
sociales évidemment vous savez très bien
les gens ne vont pas de leur propre gré
à bon groupe et avant des raisons départ
nous eh ben vous avez thonon j'ai passé
très bien les les champs ou ailleurs
vous croyez vraiment que les gens aiment
habileté à la courneuve ou à
clichy-sous-bois où les gens croyaient
qu'ils le font parce que c'est une ville
qui trouve sympa était jeune mais déjà
c'est le choix eric zemmour mais c'est
faux vous avez très bien mais vous
n'allez pas à clichy sous bois c'est
parce que vous avez les moyens de vivre
ailleurs et les gens si vous avez des
moyens dans d'autres endroits il devrait
probablement dans votre quartier -
mademoiselle
j'ai grandi en banlieue dans les enfers
était à montreuil à 10 en 2010 et je
suis j'ai donc si je ne suis plus dans
l'est dans les banlieues c'est parce que
j'ai travailé de parti c'est parce que
j'ai travailé mademoiselle j'ai
travaillé à lait ribot le banc lyonnais
travaille pas je peux parler je compare
lire ça je peux parler donc vous ne
faites pas le coup de bouvier dans les
beaux quartiers s'il vous plaît j'ai
grandi dans les banlieues et dans ma
famille avait des gens qui habitent aux
4000 de la courneuve alors on a connu
les mêmes conditions ne me faites pas le
coup du bourgeois ça marche pas partir
aux iem mais qu'ils avaient tort quand
on vient d'un pays étranger on aime bien
retrouver les siens et c'est bien humain
je ne viennent pas de là mais vous allez
arrêter de manas est ronde toutes les
deux minutes ça suffit au lycée
vous devenez agressif et che devient
agressif de ménerbes oui si l'on parle
si on coupait la parole trente secondes
on arrête je vous ai joué par les merci
je vous laisse parler alors les gens
contrairement à ce que vous dites aime
bien retrouver les leurs et c'est bien
humain on est tous comme ça oui
mademoiselle ses yeux ces lieux déjà on
va y arriver
deuxièmement
deuxièmement ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est que comme il y à une maj dans
certains quartiers une majorité de gens
qui viennent de l'immigration arabo
africaine et c'est tout à fait normal
aussi ils vivent à leur manière et donc
les gens minoritaires les français
autochtones minoritaire dès qu'ils
peuvent quand ils ont les moyens s'en
vont parce qu'il se sent rien quand ils
ont les moyens parce que pour les petits
vieux qui n'ont pas les moyens il reste
là et ils sont obligés de faire des
kilomètres pour trouver une boucherie
qui ne soit pas halal justement c'est ça
toute l'histoire est donc dès qu'ils
peuvent ils quittent ces coins là et
c'est pour ça que les gens se séparent
et c'est pour ça qu'après on parle de
ghettos et de ségrégation c'est parce
que aussi les il ya des trafics dans ces
quartiers je ne mélange pas tout du tout
dès que je ne mérite
oui il ya de la polygamie on s'est mis
en attente et il ya beaucoup de transua
du tout
et tu es pas l'apanage des quartiers
populaires au lycée nos politiques dont
notamment le maire de levallois quand
même
mais pousse et qui n'est pas issu d'un
petit paumé lequel
les milieux que vous pourrez compter et
de drogue
j'ai une petite différé tu prends
l'histoire un moment donné comme s'il
n'y avait pas une séquence avant alors
tu dis les gens abandonner veulent vivre
comme ça non dès l'instant qu'on est
contrôlé 17 fois dans la journée ça
modifie le caractère si ça t'arrive et
moi on est content
parce que la plupart des trafiquants
sont noirs et arabes c'est comme ça
c'est un fait en attend
pas forcément fait six séances n'ont pas
forcé 6,6 un beau c'est pas pire et si
effectivement moi je les verrai non mais
c'est l'américain
moi je les ai vécus dans ma propre
famille ma petite fille est métisse son
père et togolais et sur une moto arrêté
parce que noir parce que métis et on
demande les papiers et moi je suis en
voiture devant on va on est en dîners de
famille et je suis obligé d'attendre et
d'aller voir les policiers français pour
leur dire mais pourquoi vouloir demander
leurs papiers et pas à moi je vous ai
répondu non ah oui parce que une môme de
14 ans à l'époque et qui est métisse
fille potentiellement dangereux alors je
ne raconte pas l'histoire à partir de la
séquence qui t'arrange on ne fait pas
l'intégration en une génération et tu
prends à une séquence donné de
l'histoire de france 3e génération j
adore et alors ça va mettre le temps que
ça mettra mais encore une fois je te dis
tu prends 5 % de faits divers par
rapport à 95 % de choses qui se passent
bien on ne dit jamais les choses qui se
passent bien les réussites celle à 150
degrés quand il ya un truc pour finir
que je voudrais dire c'est qu'en fait
personne ne parle jamais de
l'immigration asiatique c'est à dire que
là il ya une vraie séparation mais vous
parlez de séparation il ya bien des gens
mais vivent entre eux et vous avez
séance asiatique mais vous avez sans
forcément nous sommes passés à un
nouveau modèle qui toucheront aussi et
presque d'abord à la communauté
asiatique qui est inquiète ainsi qu est
un système communautariser la mer où les
gens exact la mairie exactement ce que
ça vous embête ça moi ça me désole avant
le premier des communautarismes et blanc
et masculin il suffit de regarder la
composition au milan mais oui tu es à la
zoophilie milan eric les moules sont là
depuis deux mille ans avait
aisément parler
anormal que le parlement soit composé
aujourd'hui à 82 % d'hommes qu'il n'y
ait qu'une seule personne
présentez vous savez très bien relire
mais je ne suis pas je ne suis pas je ne
suis pas là pour être élu c'est pas
sympa l'on propose c'est de dénoncer une
assise nationale 4 au 6 mai pour 100
masculine est quand même un peu dans mes
vous mais ça n'a pas bien joué dans
laquelle ils pressentent
qu'ils représentent l'hexagone
a bien fonctionné la main
bien rock est acheté heureux de vous
connaître merci d'avoir établi et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu